they lead the two most powerful
countries in the world and for close to
two hours joe biden and xi jinping spoke
via video link about one thing
the u.s president making it crystal
clear any move in support of the russian
invasion would not be tolerated china
has to make a decision for themselves
about where they want to stand
and how they want the history books to
look at them and view their actions for
weeks china has stayed on the sidelines
refusing to condemn the actions of its
economic ally and security council
partner but after friday's call china's
state news agency reported president xi
told the u.s president the ukraine
crisis is something we don't want to see
adding that as the world's two largest
economies we must shoulder our due
international responsibilities and make
efforts for world peace i do think that
it's an opportunity also to be a
statesman for xi jinping who has
complained that china has been held back
on the international scene but china
could benefit from the conflict as well
particularly if nato members and their
resources are distracted from chinese
activities in the indo-pacific a chinese
aircraft carrier sailed through the
sensitive taiwan strait just hours
before the leaders met china will have
to do the cost and benefit analysis very
carefully if his association with this
military adventure by kremlin is much
on the cost is much greater than the
benefit of this association that china
would really have to think twice
president biden will next join nato
country leaders for that special summit
in brussels where poland's prime
minister is expected to seek support for
a peacekeeping mission into ukraine one
that would see armed nato soldiers
deployed into the country in order to
accompany humanitarian aid tracy
heather urix west reporting in
washington thank you